[Music]
hello to all while in erevan
we are therefore an sme if a little more
pope a start-up we have in rhône
somme a pure player in software testing
about sixty collaborators and
our main mission is
to  'to support our customers in the whole
dimension of quality, whether
on aspects such as cybersecurity and
interoperability, but also artificial intelligence
intelligence algorithms,
therefore within the framework of
trust for the future, this story is
what  what we do is that we specifically
develop methods to test
artificial intelligence systems and in
particular robustness we realize
that on most systems, in
particular critical systems, the notion
of performance is not sufficient  and
we need to have more
precise metrics to make sure that the system is
not going to be faulted
in cases for example like autonomous vehicles
and in other cases  i like
canton a
model is embedded in components
that we do not control embedded components
with types of cameras
that are not of very good quality
or that kind of thing so in addition to these
methods in particular we are developing a
platform  which
makes it possible to test the robustness of its
artificial intelligence algorithms
in particular for
object recognition and classification and is also
to do this same data
increase to be able and trained
the algorithms and we are very happy
to have  been selected in the
confidence program for him and this is
an opportunity for us to film and all the
technology on used cases and
to be able to make it more relevant
through collaboration between
manufacturers and to collaborate with all
the
industrial and academic fabric to be able to
produce and new methodologies
for the test
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]